[Music]
Troye Sivan proves he's a supportive
bestie recreating Lily Rose Depp's
sultry dance from the idol
[Music]
Troy who plays a creative director named
Xander in the Mac Show I was just
pulling from from some real life
experiences shared
yeah if that song and dance feel
familiar it's because it's the same song
and dance we've seen on the idol
yes
of course Lily Rose plays pop star
Jocelyn on the show and that track is
her character's latest song Do you like
the single
yeah
really Jaws is amazing K-pop icon Jenny
Ruby Jane who's a member of blackpink
also Stars alongside Lily Rose in the
idol God I wish I could dance like you
Jenny you were actually you were
literally a K-pop Idol
[Music]
[Applause]
did you give Lily any advice we did have
the conversation obviously like I'm not
a pop star so you know any kind of
insight into what it's like to be in
those shoes and everything is always
helpful and you know who best to learn
from walk power yes
[Music]
and that Tick Tock Troy posted was his
impression of himself behind the camera
watching his girls work it on set walk
[Music]
Troy you were bookended by two just
spectacular women powerhouses yeah
you're a lucky man I am I am Troy
captioned the clip with a famous quote
from the ultimate hype woman Kris Jenner
as for Lily Rose she seemingly gave
Troy's moves her stamp of approval
reposting his Tick Tock to her insta
story felt really nice to to watch her
react to it and finally get to share
something with the world that we that
we're all so proud of ET chatted with
Lily Bros Troy and Jenny last month at
the Cannes Film Festival where they
received a five-minute Standing Ovation
it was incredible like it felt like such
a beautiful celebration and like
culmination of of everything that we've
been through together and creating this
little family together and it just felt
really really nice and special to get to
celebrate together and there's a lot to
celebrate the idols Premiere episode had
more viewers than the series premieres
of euphoria in 2019 and the White Lotus
in 2021. we're just so
um happy with the response